it is good to be back and I am honored
to be here in more ways than I can
possibly express so I'll settle for
touching on just too first I am very
aware that this is the year of
celebrating women at Yale
now I'm not of the first gen having
arrived on campus ten years after that
50th anniversary pioneering crew
arriving as parts of Saybrook class of
83 I can attest that Yale was is very
good to me I was a naive
wet-behind-the-ears public high school
student from a small town in
Massachusetts looking back I was a nerd
whale gave me the chance to study
archaeology that my childhood dream gave
me an unassailable foundational pedigree
gave me the opportunity to continue my
education at Cambridge on a Claire
Mellon fellowship made it possible for
me to have the career that I have had I
owe
Yale and this is a good year to
acknowledge that debt now after
graduating I stayed in New Haven over
the summer and I worked in sterling
library I worked in the archives and
such were those largely pre-digital
times the preserving archival materials
involved a lot of I'm sorry to say
xeroxing and REE boxing with acid-free
materials and I did these tasks most
diligently but my pace was significantly
slowed when I was assigned to work on
call number ms1 1 3 3 the michael
ivanovitch rostov chef papers all 13.2
five glorious linear feet now I knew of
course of Rostov chef but it would be
another couple years yet during my
doctoral work before I would be
enraptured in awe of the scope and
stretch of the social and economic
history
of the Hellenistic world be inspired by
his big thinking his confidence it even
had pictures yeah but earlier they're in
the bowels of sterling god knows where
they are now but then they were in the
bowels of Sterling there I saw his
handwriting saw his lectures witnessed
his drafts and his letters touch things
that he had touched there was kind of a
materiality to my contact with a man and
his work materiality of course is a
happy thing for archaeologists and I
remember those contacts now and beyond
honored to deliver a lecture bearing his
name now the work I want to springboard
off tonight however is not that man of
social and economic history of the
Hellenistic world
aka se ahw nor its companion the se HRW
instead it's a smaller and less formal
volume caravan cities published in 1932
smaller less formal now this project had
actually started even earlier as kind of
a set of travel writing sort of travel
sketches really and there is still very
much that flavour to the book a book
that is a product of a younger and less
said Rostov set and in it he tells of
early 20th century visits to Jairus
Palmyra of course dura europas of Yale
University art gallery Fame and the
first site discussed he visited Petra in
southern Jordan now the question of
caravan cities is very straightforwardly
framed what do I mean by the term
Caravan City Rostov says asks though
perhaps he doesn't as straightforwardly
answer it but that is not the topic I
want to discuss today instead what I'd
like to do is is to make some sort of
con some kind of contact again between
Rostov Saif and myself to take what he
made of Petra you know what he saw what
he noted
what he felt and connected back was
aspects of my own and others fieldwork
at the site and in its hinterland some
90 odd years on all right quick timeout
two introductions Petra very famous
who's been o people o iyx s gotta get
their thumbnail sketch Petra thumbnail
sketch Petra an archaeological site and
the Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan and the
blue box right there
history best known historically is the
capital of the Nabataean Kingdom a
regional Western Asian power the map
there in the red lines gives you sort of
the notional sense of the kingdom's
principal heartland the NAB's as they're
sometimes affectionately known played a
major role in the ancient east-west
trade including the so called incense
route marked by a train a train here of
little tiny camels here B caravans give
you a sense of the geography of the site
and it's networks
now as for chronology the Nabataean
kingdom and the development of the city
of Petra was at its height during the
Hellenistic era continued to do well
after annexation by Rome and 106 C
eventually was swallowed up by other
empires under which the city endured
before dropping off the you know Western
radar so that's just a little history
but what Petra and of course the name
means rocks
what Petra is really famous for is just
that it's rocks for its vibrant
architectural display you see here a
sampling of tombs and theaters and
houses with its cityscape cut into the
local rose red beautifully variegated
sandstone bedrock now one more set of
introductions less famous I'm afraid is
the
Brown University Petra archaeological
project this is a project I co-directed
by myself it's now in a publication
phase now while this project did some
work down in the city itself this is
Petra down here Petra lies as we'll be
hearing about down in a valley for the
most part the project worked in the
large plateau up above to the north of
the city basically from the shara
mountains a mountain ridge that will
come into question later down to the
drop OOP oh bugger
there we go drop I'm gonna that's gonna
happen a few more times folks it's a
very small thing down dropped into the
wadi are above there we did regional
landscape survey and i'm happy to talk
more about that in a bit now this work
it's ongoing successor project is the
brown university petra terraces
archaeological project this is
co-directed by felipe rojas at brown and
sarah newman at chicago and they are
doing a deeper dive into the
agricultural landscape of that same area
to the north
now archaeological acronyms are rarely
euphonious but I think we rather outdid
ourselves and probably not in a good way
with boop app and bucked app
respectively that's enough introductions
back to rust offset now Petra is the the
sketchiest city visited in the book and
I should add sketchy in the sense of
retaining the more travelogue style of
narrative not any judgement verdict now
rust also spends only sixteen pages on
Petra out of the 226 total of Caravan
cities and in the course of this he
essentially walks through the site
it's a highly experiential perspective
now it's only 16 pages but they are a
rollicking good read and I want to give
you a taste of some of the flavor a
little bit redacted but I think you
should hear his at least at least his
translated voice in this lecture in his
honor and while I do that
there's a published plan his published
plan of the site to study while I give
you the kickoff of those 16 pages that's
rust offset some 19 years ago when I
first went to Palestine the starting
point for a visit to Petra Amman and
Josh it was not only a lengthy and
difficult but also a complicated and
expensive business to assent to attempt
to see these cities and in one in which
a young professor of st. Petersburg
University could ill afford now in the
Palestine of today all this has been
altered the English have appeared
bringing in their wake like the Romans
before them order and safety good roads
and new means of transport in Palestine
the motorcar has now succeeded the super
seat of the camel while the Sultan's
Arad the councillor kvass and the
Turkish Apia have been replaced by mr.
Thomas cook by one of his talkative
guides and by the police force of the
trans Jordanian Emir and a mom there has
appeared a hotel which is comparatively
speaking clean and in the valley of
Petra Thomas Cook has already pitched
his camp Hotel its bedrooms consists of
tents or of the rock tombs rock houses
or rock stables of ancient Petra
tourists are followed in the wake of
these innovations and today those who
visit your ash and Petra are no longer
to be counted in units as in the past
but in tens and hundreds soon no doubt
they will come in their thousands
he continues roast off Saif does and I
give you now a view of the site the new
rulers of Palestine and Transjordan eeeh
do their utmost to further the tourist
development of the district the local
populace show neither opposition nor
friendliness towards this policy and
they delight in preying on the foreigner
without violating the law by selling him
minor antiquities or something of the
Slender produce of the country the
Bedouin from the desert frowned on the
tourists and are not averse from
relapsing to their old cuss
of highway robbery they are however made
to pay a heavy price for such misdeeds
for Mon on the petra road stands the
camp of the new trans jordanian legion
the cavalry section of this force is
mounted on horses and camels in much the
same way as the roman troops of old
ready to pounce upon the bedouin of the
desert and to exact retribution for
their incursions or for the kidnapping
of foreigners as a result European and
American ladies run but a very slender
chance of being carried off by some wild
Arab sheikh and must fall back upon such
romantic incidents as may happen in
Petra's tents and quote yeah there's a
lot in there on which true reflects so
very very much has changed of course and
yet there nonetheless remain you know
numerous echoes and resonances today and
an incarnation of the thomascook camp
hotels seen there on the left is still
there in the valley of petra it's called
nozzles camp that this succeeds the
tents and it indeed is still used by
visiting archaeological teams who aren't
too fussy about cleanliness rasathi
was also spot on regarding tourism not
only did they come in their thousands
but in their tens of thousands petra was
voted some of you may remember this a
new wonder of the world in 2007 and
petra remains an essential anchor for
the significant economic driver that is
the jordanian tourism economy visitor
numbers of of course oscillated over the
years given you know regional
insecurities much i should add to the
hardship of the local Bedouin population
who serviced the site today it's
expected however that at least this year
petra has bounced back and will log 1
million visitors by christmas the
selling of minor antiquities still
continues you see here painted ceramics
coins
lamps if you ask nicely they'll show you
you prehistoric stone tools this goes on
still with little punishment if not
quite now without violating the law with
the shake appearing in 1921 that
contemporaneous rudolph valentino like
reference to wild Arab sheiks might
appear amusing but there is actually a
just and disturbingly an active romantic
Bedouin sex travel scam sort of sex
tourism dimension very very much so to
visitor traffic at Petra documented
extensively on the internet with titles
such as Jack Sparrow in Jordan if oh
come on folks
captain nevermind that's Captain Jack
Sparrow to you it's material traces can
also be memorably traced through
archaeological reconnaissance and I will
leave it at that now such sort of
flashes of recognition repeated patterns
reflective patterns keep coming in
various ways reading through Petra's
Petra in caravan cities another for
example is restof sis reaction to the
passage through the seek a sneaking
kilometre or so long water cut entrance
into the heart of Petra basically this
is how the tourists and visitors come
into the city and a view to views of the
seek to show you what it looks like and
as you wiggle through this narrow chasm
you begin to sense a sort of an epiphany
at hand the appearance of something
wonderful yet to come now rostoff saif
is literally you know by this time in
history literally just one of millions
of people who hitting this point in this
space stopped stared took and published
in every quality and conceivable media
known to humanity a money shot capturing
this truly astonishing tada
moment of movement from darkness into
light and there you see on the left hand
that's published by
stops up in caravan cities on the right
hand Annie Leibowitz taking a photo
Susan Sontag in exactly the same place
and this could be replicated again and
again and again and again on any Google
search the big reveal of course the
Treasury el khazneh and one final sort
of I've heard this song before on his
peregrinations rust offset comments in
passing and he says and to the right an
entire wall is covered with the most
astonishing facade
they are the hellenistic tombs the most
renowned of all Petra's monuments those
with which we have become familiar to
their frequent reproduction in cinema
films that's restof 7 published in 1932
and I'm trying very hard to pin down
what cinema films were being used we're
using Petra is background in the early
20th century because what's remarkable
is that one could basically repeat that
sentence today if now more you know for
the cosmetic and the Hellenistic tombs
and I would cite among others you know
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
and I'm sorry to say transformers 2 yeah
so choose wisely family so you know
Pluto songs in certain ways there is
however another more insidious way in
which rust off SEFs
on Petra is intensely familiar and that
is in his astonished rapture at the
beauty of the site coupled with a sort
of perceived air of its unreality and
this is just well I give you another
quote from him I'll show you various
views this is up above looking down on
the side of Petra just orient you will
be talking about the main colonnaded
street something called the great temple
you can anchor on the columns erected
there the wadi musa which is basically
the
you all know what a wadi is Inter
ministry bed good yeah
basically the Sikh is was cut by the
wadi musa so this is what rust off saif
says much has already been written about
petra and i do not wish to repeat what
has already been told i am tempted
almost to liken the city to some wonder
from the arabian nights when one
descends into the valley from the
surrounding heights toward the place
where the river has cut for itself a
passage between the dark red rocks one
seems to be gazing at some large and
fantastic
x crescents a piece of reddish move raw
flesh set between the gold of the desert
and the green of the hills it is a most
extraordinary site which becomes even
more extraordinary when the cavalcade
slowly descends into the river valley
and the rocky walls of the ever
narrowing gorge power up to right and
left speckled with red orange mow grey
and green layers wild and beautiful they
are with their contrasts of light and
shade the light blinding the shadows
black and there is seldom even anything
to remind the visitor that this gorge
served for centuries as a main road
trodden by camels mules and horses and
that along it rode bedouin merchants who
must have felt like ourselves its horror
and mystic fascination end quote
now this sensorial somewhat purple prose
is a light motif of writing about and
representation of petra it goes back at
least to a poem written in 1835 that's
about 30 years after the site's western
rediscovery a british clergyman one john
william bergen who never got within an
ass's roar of petra but his very long
and in many ways wonderful poem yet
perfume much perception of the rose-red
City and I just because I can't resist
it I'll read it to you it seems no work
of man's creative hand by Labor rot as
wavering fancy planned but from the rock
as if by magic alone grown eternal
silent beautiful alone and matched me
such marvel save in eastern climb a rose
red city half as old as time and that
last line is much quoted and is the
kicker now such representation was
underscored by images such as this of
the Treasury by the Orientalist painter
David Roberts in the early 19th century
with its focus on the monument the pink
with a minimal use of local indigenous
population for scale in other words you
know one can track and there many touch
points in this one can track
clearly from Robert Sandberg on to rust
off Saif and others of his generation to
tourist photo tags and comments today
well you know when you would can track
the ingredients of a powerful and still
very prevalent image of Petra and its
history and that is you know the beauty
of ancient rose red rocks with which the
human has had little to do no work of
man's creative hand Petra is simply a
marvel a piece of reddish mow raw flesh
set between the gold of the desert and
the green of the hills a place of horror
and mystic fans fascination and I could
quote restof saif at other points as he
makes his way through this wonder of the
Arabian Nights Petra he says is the
setting for a scene in some gigantic
fairyland theater and quote elsewhere a
new vision appears and so on and so on
now Petra is indeed spectacular and I
use that word advisedly yet such
embedded perceptions or such pattern
of perception have I believed long
contributed to a certain view of the
site creating a degree of astigmatism
shall we say in our understanding of the
city and of those who built and dwelled
in it perhaps mostly by not always
seeing those who built and dwelled in it
these are perceptions that may have
contributed to the relative atomization
of the archaeological exploration of the
city long conducted on a sort of a
structure by structure architectural II
driven basis with little attempt to map
a dynamic cityscape to look for agency
or for actors I think it's contributed
perhaps to the rather flat
representation of the Nabataeans though
their limited historical voice and
inscriptions roster are soft self
sniffed by the way that the latter the
inscriptions were poor in content I
think that you know is admittedly
another factor they could have used a
passe Gnaeus and they could it
contributed also perhaps to the minimal
recognition of any sense of descent of
local populations to the people who
built the amazing very human site that
today's Bedouin communities once lived
in and still live near and depend upon
now much recent work at the site has
sought in various ways to correct and
sort of contextualize such visioning to
augment and anchor them through some
different lenses and to illustrate just
some of these you know what I'll call
new ways of seeing though through
perhaps less rose-colored glasses if you
will forgive a pun sorry I want now to
sort of pivot to two themes into two
places at Petra which you know while
they are not totally invisible in
Caravan cities they're not truly present
either given
you know rust officer primary engagement
with what he considered and called the
most wonderful Caravan City located as
he saw it in a fairy lamp theater so two
themes to places in other words where I
think rostov SEF requires considerable
reflection and hence my highly
photoshopped image right there now to be
clear this is reflection not critique
partial viewings and partial tellings
are part and parcel of the genre of
travel writing in which caravan cities
was born and as all archaeologists are
you know are painfully aware Rosoff SEF
surely accepted that his narrative would
be altered indeed it's clear that he
rewrote parts of what would become
caravan cities after additional travels
and seeing newly available
archaeological evidence you know he
basically went back and rewrote palmyra
he rewrote dura europas Petra I think
was not one of was not treated however
in that way it behooves me to remember
as well as to share with you that
actually very very little excavation had
been done at Petra at the time of his
visit it is amazing really that he
extracted as much of value as he did so
I I like to think that he would
appreciate this kind of update
now the first of my two themes revolves
around something on which rust off SEF
rarely dwells a certain noun appears
only 31 times in caravan cities and only
three times in Petra's 16 pages but to
be fair when it does occur it is loaded
with significance charged with
adjectives and the elements in question
is water or in rostov SEFs texts
vivifying water life-giving water
reviving water water worth its weight in
gold
so my first theme then is the necessity
and the complexity of water in a
semi-arid region of highly variable
seasonal precipitation not least in an
urban context with an urban population
plus visitors to tend and to feed and I
think we can add to that of course the
need to control water what you see here
is a shot this is the seek and during
the flash flooding of 2018 a very highly
highly dangerous situation now that
first theme when you start pulling on it
water the importance of centrality of
water once you start pulling on it that
leads inevitably to the second oops
sorry opening our eyes to the sheer
breathtaking amount of human
intervention and manipulation visible
ubiquitous in this supposedly natural
fabulous someone somewhat you know in
human landscape
now if Rostov Ceph winding through the
seek says there seldom even anything to
remind the visitor that this gorge
served for centuries as a main road
trodden by camels and mules and horses
well then blight HANA blinded by the
moments perhaps he's just not looking
because there are traces abounding
throughout to the seek carved niches
sacred symbols such as this triple
baitul inscriptions graffiti
and water features everywhere channels
dams tunnels and more here water
channels lining large chunks of the seek
the human other words visible human
touches everywhere I want to zoom out
for just a minute here that the visible
human touches the high degree of
intervention modulation modification Oh
keep using the Asian words that we see
in the seek the same density and
multiplicity of such things can be found
as well across the city that you see
here and not only the city itself but
across the entire regional landscape the
hinterland of Petra everything that you
see in this image the hinterland of
Petra the regions where the boop app and
bucked app and many others have worked
and have traced mechanisms for water
capture and control hydraulic
engineering features and systems of
features numbered in the hundred if not
in the thousands in this landscape and I
you know at first I thought I would just
come and talk to you about Petra in the
work at Petra then I thought no I should
tie it more to rust off Saif but I could
speak a bit more to the work done by
boop app and bupt app again efforts down
in the city centre but largely a
large-scale Archaeological Survey
regional surface survey in the area to
the north there to you know again to our
surprise the more we look the more we
found of water features this is for
example just one Wadi and all of this I
should say is about a five minute drive
from Petra this is not remote this is
next door no one just bothered to look
closely you see here a huge system of
dam features that basically run from the
shara mountains all the way down to the
wadi bacaw and what's going on here is a
sort of an engineered landscape a
carefully engineered landscape that led
to the development of a productive
very much needed so close to the city
center now Hristov SEF doesn't speak to
this territory as petra the countryside
was not at all on his radar
yet it was a countryside put to
intensive work in service of the city he
praises and I'm happy to discuss all
this more and I will show you just one
more image of the results of this work
this is just a sort of a mapping of
features found by the Brown University
Petra archaeological project and all the
blue and all the brown are basically
water features and agricultural features
and so when I speak to the hundreds and
dozens and thousands of features and and
human interventions that is what I'm
talking about but for tonight I think
let's I want to stay in downtown Petra
and with rostoff SEF and think about
water and its manipulations first theme
and second theme about intensive human
investments in the landscape and how the
introduction of these subjects modify in
turn rust offsets account now
appropriately I think the first place we
will look to is a market now to be fair
rust offset viewed Petra not only as a
site as an SI ght a site of wonder and
awe but he does acknowledge it as a town
of the living a town such as mecca was
before the time of muhammad it was a
city of rich and wily merchants and
that's how he speaks of its activity and
he read what was known about the city
from that perspective seeing in its then
visible bones markets camels spices and
business so here he is on downtown petra
inside the walls the plan of the city
was dictated by caravan trade the main
thoroughfare is the road which follows
the course of the main river the wadi
musa here's a wadi musa and the main the
main street which has been partially
canalized in part
they covered over a so-called triumphal
arch an ornamental gate the ruins of
which still survived was thrown across
the the River Street on one side of this
Main Street temples and public buildings
were arranged in terraces overlooking
the city and he's talking about this
side of the street here and I'll be
referring to the Great Temple and these
three squares or markets in a second two
temples still stand as superb ruins and
there's the great temple again and the
general outlines of the three large
marketplaces this is still rust off SEF
are still recognizable here bargains
work included here bankers merchants
middlemen and their agents carried on
their business here gold and precious
stones changed hands here ginger peel
and thyme smells sweetly and the air was
filled with the pleasant perfume of
incense and that of other odorous leaves
and roots brought from India and Arabia
that's Rosoff saif on the activity in
the marketplaces so let's look at them a
little more closely these are the three
big apparently open spaces upper market
middle market lower market named as
restof SEF sign them nomenclature if
increasingly now these days placed in
scare quotes as markets now part of the
Brown University Petra archaeological
project involved a small excavation in
one of these you see that in the upper
left-hand corner in the upper market
what we chiefly discovered admittedly it
was very small sort of a leper squint
kind of dig what we discovered was a
subterranean system of waterworks and
channels clearly supporting a sort of a
broader network of other structures
especially fountain structures more
definite functionality eluded us other
work by boo pap under the Great Temple
the one of the other temples the soft
surface mentions similarly discovered
endless chains of water channels and
cisterns we performed
ground-penetrating radar as seen in Nova
that's me there looking like I know what
I'm doing you know just yeah he just
excellent results again pointing to
massive amounts of water intervention
and literally right next door to the
Great Temple another team took a market
the lower market and made of it
literally a garden this was work out of
a team led by Li and boodle at a Penn
State Erie and they've revealed what is
today called as you see the Petra garden
and pool complex right next to the Great
Temple this has also been turned turned
and I think a happy turn of phrase a
triumph of forensic Landscape
Architecture which is three words I
never thought to hear in conjunction now
in this garden and pool complex you see
how dry is a bone and flat and boring it
all looks there they found garden
features pools flower pots botanical
Romain's waterfalls all made possible by
water drawn and driven from the
considerable distances of high mountains
and from local rains so you can see here
they sorry about that an island pavilion
terraced walls a waterfall and small
building circular cisterns and on and on
a very elaborate space now this paradise
while I might as well go ahead and give
it to you feast your eyes on that this
paradise or parody sauce has been
variably reconstructed this is a rather
bright version that's the Great Temple
to the left and the ring sort of
coloration to the to the to the to the
pool and garden complex this one might
be slightly more palatable
I find for Americans of a certain age
this all tends to bring on a sort of an
irresistible desire to reminisce about
the Beverly Hillbillies and their world
of swimming pools and movie stars or the
Nova documentary took it to the next
step in some things up is
Etra the Las Vegas of the ancient world
which a bridge too far perhaps now
Mart's most seriously what all this
various work is doing is to taking
current interpretations of this zone of
Petra and suggesting that in Nabataean
in Roman times you know far from markets
you know hands-on Haven for bankers
merchants and middlemen at least as
envisioned by rostoff SEF this garden of
this paradise this you know very highly
water spoiled part of the site would
have been devoted to elite likely royal
ceremonial religious and leisure uses
and spaces and indeed it's kind of
gotten to the point these days that few
even imagine that the camels actually
ever came downtown though again rostov
chef's description still has whiffs that
work for the space probably did spell
sweetly and the air was filled with a
pleasant perfume of incense and that of
other odorous leaves and roots brought
from India and Arabia so that's sort of
two themes one place let's stick to
themes water in its manipulation
intensive human investments in the
landscape and turn to the second again I
want to give kudos to rostoff saif for a
keen eye and very good instincts about a
site that in his time had only just
begun to reveal itself now there's a
tendency both popular and academic to
envision the seek that sinuous Canyon as
the only entrance into Petra which led
for a long time
to great concern about how they got all
those caravans of camels in through that
narrow Gorge and this even got taken to
the point of being thought to be a
source for the new template testament
parable about the you know through a
needles eye which seems highly unlikely
to me actually there are several access
routes into Petra from both north and
south and restof self examined noticed
unusually and examine some of those that
ran from the city center
out for example one case he says on the
north close to the fortress of L hobbies
- romantic gorges s SIA and Elmo Ezra
and this is Elmo Ezra you see here and
basically it runs down towards the site
of Petra heading south
these have been explored by mister horse
felled and miss Conway they found their
remains of several large and rich houses
cut in the rock some of these houses
were at a later date converted into
tombs and I'm hoping you guys can make
out with the light some of the
structures that he's he's talking about
here some of these are houses some were
originally tombs some were converted he
thinks he goes on to say that it's
probable that the rock-cut houses of the
two gorges represent the dwellings of
the inhabitants of Petra of the time
when it first became a flourishing
center of Caravan trade on that one but
in other words he saw these romantic
gorges as residential zones or
necropolis and this is another view of
the wedding Moira with a tomb to the
right there nestled in the in the
bedrock and that's not wrong but we now
can populate these spaces in numerous
other ways as well take for example a
look at the this map of the various
features and elements that both brown
projects have observed in the wadi Moira
so here's oh can you guys see my
blocking you see the cistern channel
agricultural production dam tears
inscription Beatle nephesh tomb Road
stair quarry cave house and then over on
this side you can see the patterning
I'll just say a lot of the rock cut the
houses that rust off so if we're talking
about we're down here close to the Petra
city centre and you also see tombs don't
worry too much about the details but
basically just focus on the number of
symbols on the map we
have sacred markings we have graffiti we
have portions of portions of roads still
used by goatherds today I hope you can
see the goats wandering along there in
other words what we have here is not
sort of you know a residential zone we
have a highly sculptured pathway from
the city centre out to its regional
hinterland and coming back again now
that was all very interesting of what
really had not been anticipated was the
intense cultivation of these corridors
there used for agricultural activity and
thus the necessary ubiquity of water
management features again cisterns
channels dams terraces all woven
together you know along these you know
as you see very steep slopes to capture
and harvest water coming from above one
additional feature I'd like to to point
out just to show the extremes that they
took this - these are something called
stairs seen everywhere in the landscape
around Petra basically there's sort of
vertical water features like ladders
almost so can you see them sorry cut it
the you see why they call them stairs
and you know they probably were also
used for sort of access up and down but
largely what they seemed have been used
for was when the rains come the hard
driving rains that what the stairs would
do was sort of judder the water flow
slow it down allow it to be controlled
and you see here that basically these
are going way way up and there are even
more examples of stairs heading further
and further up the slopes we don't you
know oh let's put it this way well above
where we would let our graduate students
go you know so there's an obsession here
with capturing every single drop we can
reconstruct as we put together these
agricultural bits and pieces we can
reconstruct sort of small complexes of
different sort of to create little
catchments for cultivation this is one
kind of one
and I won't walk you through it in any
detail but here we have Bush you know
sorry I'd apologize there we go
sort of a water runoff through the you
know down the little stairs captured in
a cistern flow down towards agricultural
terraces which retain soil therefore
allowing a sort of a buildup of soil for
cultivation cisterns more terraces more
water runoff on and on and on now these
these are not large systems these are
not big contiguous systems we are not
talking amber waves of grain here rather
they are very specific almost sort of
surgical insertions into the landscape
and they're all intensifying in their
very small ways the utilization of this
Wadi system they create a kind of a
mosaic of gardens or market gardens and
they are very meticulously cleverly
planned and in place they are also I
should say very hard to illustrate I
mean you've probably noticed in this in
this talk you know that you know
photographs don't really do it plans
don't really do it
so what we're been increasingly buck tap
are doing is moving towards artistic
renderings watercolors impressionistic
imagery useful in trying to convey the
scale and intricacy of these small
systems so you know here we we have here
a cistern being approached by donkey
again for scale small pockets of green
and this is a view basically looking one
imagination of looking down the wadi
towards petra and these pockets of
cultivation in other words yes people
lived and were buried in the wadi mara
but to put it in context we can now see
that these romantic as rostoff said
these rocky canyons what at least at
certain periods of time have been
crowded peopled cultivated trafficked
roadways into a city that was also
liberally patched with green one could
say a garden city
now if one considers much if by no means
all recent work at Petra much embraces
these new kinds of themes and scales of
analysis there's been something of a
shift in emphasis in other words on what
aspects of the social and economic
history of Petra our champion from the
Rostov sofyan themes of Trade and
distance to exploring the local in the
quotidian the agricultural and the
managed the site in its regional context
and not just as a node in a wider world
a move perhaps towards Petra as a more
lived place and less space of wonder and
of awe now some of this I think may have
to do with contemporary and pressing
concerns on the ground water has taken
over Petra scholarship and I think you
may see one reason why here some in
other words maybe you know more a matter
of archaeologists just seeking space to
do fresh work and save fresh things one
of the big drivers behind the Brown
University Petra archaeological project
moving forward however I think one thing
is certain and that is that the answer
is not to change caravan cities to
garden cities calling any city an ex
city or a why city just seems like a bad
idea we must remember also that you know
Petra's Manifest role is part you know
of a long human chain as a caravan city
with at least a lowercase C and we're
going to have eventually - and we're
gonna have to reconnect the multiple
strands at work around the site and
reconcile their narratives in other
words we have to continue to reflect and
build on our understanding of patterns
at Petra now no doubt it's coming back
to college
that leaves me thinking in generational
terms of that essential academic work of
continual building
reflection reassessment paradigm
shifting building again always on the
basis of what comes before I can do no
better in conclusion than to quote rust
offset from caravan cities on this theme
he said we the archeologists of the 20th
century are working on the basis
established for us by our predecessors
of the eighteenth and nineteenth those
travelers who were the first to collect
the inscriptions to draw and photograph
the ruins of the most important
buildings to measure them and to make a
general plan and he was saying a thank
you as he ignores he acknowledged the
contribution of his predecessors I think
so the archaeologists of the 21st
century working on the basis established
for us must acknowledge his intern I
think we all pay it forward and as
grandiloquence and cheesy powerful and
of its time as it is I will also leave
you with rust off says final
encouragement that people go to Petra
that they spend several nights in that
fantastic crater listen with open ears
to the nocturnal chorus of jackals and
make a pilgrimage to the mountain
sanctuaries thus they may feel something
of the departed life of ancient Petra
the most wonderful of all the caravan
cities in the region where through the
sand of mourning land the camel bears
the spice thank you very much and
boola-boola
I'm sorry I kept hitting the wrong
button there that's a fat fingers they
don't get any questions oh I'm not
supposed to move I think oh oh do i me
to do my poor lunch date shall I take a
couple questions please yes I'm happy to
take some questions please you must go
to Yale yeah
chronology chronology is an issue here
there is no question and a lot of the
rock cut features the puzzle is how to
is how to date them you know a rocket
channel is a rocket channel so we have
to we have to use some proxy data and
that's where some of the work of the the
survey work of the braun project comes
in where we have sort of high points of
settlement high points of activity now
you can be a little dangerous to say
that associates but you know if you
consider in the cuy historical context
of having a city that needs to be fed
and this is a local agricultural
catchment so it makes sense to to tag
the intensive modifications to the
periods of what seemed to be high
pressure high population high population
demand and that is you know is a peak is
the Nabataean starting late Hellenistic
through middle say middle Roman period
at that time Nabataean to Roman is is is
tricky and this is a battle right now in
some ways that some people want you know
the tradition is to say 106 Trajan comes
along you know Petra you know goes goes
off that goes off the radar I think what
they are some of the more lanes
or and more other recent archaeological
evidence is suggesting is much less
there's no real distinct disjunct at
that at that point and so the Nabataean
roman is the political change should not
be seen as an economic or even perhaps
as a social change which is something
that makes perfect sense
but you know it is it is a good question
then people could say you know you know
how can you date what you're talking
about and that is basically what buck
tap the following project is beginning
to do in more detail they are actually
god bless them digging some of these
systems you know which basically means
digging behind terrace walls which
basically means digging very large deep
holes not trying to find a damn thing
except dirt so that they can get either
radiocarbon or OSL material to date and
that's going to be the essential next
step so so I'm playing a little fast and
loose here with you know the
intensification but I think it makes
sense and especially in the city center
it's very clear that these water
channels are tied to the period the
intensely active period when Petra is
getting built they're all it's part of
that late Hellenistic zone so please
say their agricultural areas any
evidence of what they in the in the in
the garden pool complex they have quite
a variety and in the end some imported
plants whose names like I can't remember
but their ornamental and flowering and
not not so much you know food in in the
garden pool complex not we don't have
anything for the water moister yet
they're they're collecting samples some
of the interestingly some of the
terraces out in the Northland the area
where blue PAP was working fruit trees
and nut trees was some of the the pollen
the pollen that they got one additional
interesting source of information is
there's a in there's a place called
Little Petra which has a triclinium
painted ceiling in one of the triclinium
that is just you know I sort of like
there's 16 different kinds of grape
represented there there's 22 different
kinds of ivy it's it's like a became a
botanical you know sort of textbook and
now obviously we're not saying that that
was rep really represented what was
grown locally but there's clearly you
know highly developed you know sort of
awareness of plant life which is if any
of you get to Southern Jordan in the
summer which is when all of us get to go
not when there's rain well you know is
is what the so the disjunct between the
dryness of the present and the apparent
lushness of the past it is very clear
that they were also growing grapes which
is another shock
there are many wine presses found in the
area that we surveyed and there's a
rather optimistic gentleman who is
described Petra as the the Bordeaux of
the Nabataean world so sir
this water engine yeah smiley is there
anyone
understood how the water fell down early
this is a comedian
yeah one thing I would say and I wasn't
quite sure I could how to bring it in
but you know I'm talking about the
ladders as a as a sort of a water
capture and control device it's a it's
also very clear that some of the
placement of them in certain complexes
near tombs is that it seems to have been
partly you know to slow the water and
calm the water and collect the water but
also that it was just a beautiful thing
you know it so it's you know it's like a
fountain in a way it you know bubbling
and aerating and the sound the auditory
sound there's been some work done at
this complex called little Petra which
is a series of tombs and and triclinium
and there's some of these these stairs
near there and they've done some
experimentation with water flow to what
you know sort of we kind of white noise
as it were in the background so that's
one thing I would say the second thing
is you know it's an interesting question
on the engineering someday there will be
you know there's gonna be a mosh pit
battle between Nabataean and Roman
experts because I think some folks will
tell you that a lot of you know the
Romans invented water engineering that a
lot of that actually starts King Herod
is another example there are things
going on in the East that may have moved
to the West rather than you know then
everything being invented in the central
Mediterranean but we don't have and this
is where the the sort of the textual
record lets us stand we don't have the
sense or the records of training or who
figured it out or but see I think it
does raise the you know you know maybe
there were children of nature and they
just gut it you know I mean which I
think ties too closely into this oh man
they're living in this pink Wonderland
and of course they knew how to do these
you know that we're not thinking about
them as human agents and a fully rounded
sense and I think that's that's what
makes me cautious so it's kind of a
roundabout answer you
question sorry please I think answers a
little bit all all of the above I'm
there is not though I think it's it's
growing there's not this kind of we we
live locally in the Nabataeans are our
ancestors there's some of that but
surprisingly little given I should
should just underline that the local
Bedouins the padule population live used
to live in the in this in the site and
basically got kicked out in the 1980s
and local you know concrete new
settlement was constructed for them to
move into which is inadequate and
increasingly inadequate so you would
think there would be that kind
Lin you know that's the that's our home
but not not as developed as you know in
some countries where you have this very
tight connection to what is perceived as
the people who came before and I think
that's again I'm wondering if some of
that is this Petra's not a product of
past people Petra is a force of nature
literally I think most of the struggle
or the struggles and activism of the
padule tends to be more around current
current treatment and current current
economic politics it's a it's especially
with the vicissitudes of the tourist
trade which directly hits you know hits
hits hits the you know the only real
source of their livelihood so I think it
tends to be more struggles with the
central government with the central
government with the with the monarchy
about like what kind of cut they should
get from you know the the revenues of
the site not so much about about
about their relationship with the past
please sufficient in antiquity to the
population you know interesting question
I think's probably too soon to say we've
only intensively looked at a small area
and and I'm sure the catchment for Petra
was was was larger and then there's you
know the whole region to the to the
south of the city the city as well I
think I think more the question is you
know why did it take so long for people
to actually think about how petrol was
feeding it was feeding itself and I
think there was this assumption for a
long time or just kind of in if you know
that they're just there they're carting
it all in you know and which makes no
real sense when you think about what
Caravan trade trade should be for I mean
I can even back it up it's funny about
Petra we know so much in some ways and
yet we also know so little some people
will tell you the population of Petra
was you know thirty thousand people at
its height others will tell you it was a
hundred and twenty thousand people and
you know and partly we the necessary
work to sort of map the site the city of
the urban zone itself has you know has
not been done sufficiently to really get
a sense of sort of residential
populations or density of population so
to even answer your question I think you
know we you know we have to sort out
both the hinterland production but also
what is what is the urban population and
then you know how many people are coming
through to stay and be taking care of in
this caravan trade is you know as we
increasingly wonder where the hell were
all those camels kept you know which is
an ongoing an ongoing topic please
what is evidence what is the major
evidence that leads archaeology to say
you know I think when one folks like
we're soft stuff showed up and there
were these big empty squares which you
know until fairly recently I mean past
15 years remained as visible empty
squares
I think the automatic mindset was this
is a caravan city what's going on in
here the camels are coming down the main
road where the camels gonna or you know
the camels the traders the businessman
we have these nice Agora spaces often
and that I think was you know without
other kinds of evidence that was the
assumption and you know as I go this is
the Great Temple and it's right next to
the markets and that ties are the
importance of of trade and you know you
can sort of see how the narrative
develops it's no one's fault it's just
how it emerged it was only when you know
excavation started it's like there's no
there's a there seemed to be no sign of
you know commercial activity really
anywhere in downtown Petra and then be
something like the garden and pool
complex is discovered and it's like I
think we have to rethink you know you
know the urban you know the urban makeup
of this city center and that's you know
that's still a work in progress but it
was a shock to a lot of people when they
started pulling out flowerpots and pools
and it's like hell is good you know so
so it's a so it's one of those you know
and it happens it's being an
archaeologist you learn to be humble
because you know give give some
whippersnapper graduates graduate
student a shovel and they're gonna go
out and prove you all wrong you just and
you just accept it so oh wait
purse-snatcher graduate students soon
[Applause]
[Music]